S
WEEK.
IT'S AMAZING.
IN NEW YORK, MIGRANTS ACCUSED OF
TRASHING THE LUXURY TAXPAYER
FUNDED HOTEL THAT NEW YORK IS
USING FOR THEM TO STAY IN.
A STAFFER THERE FINALLY COULDN'T
TAKE IT ANYMORE, SO HE BLEW THE
WHISTLE.
HE SAYS IT'S TOTAL CHAOS IN
THESE HOTELS, THAT THE MIGRANTS
ARE DRINKING ALL DAY, GETTING
INTO FIGHTS, THROWING AWAY TONS
OF THE DAILY MEALS THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED TO THEM.
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS IS NOT HAVING
IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE FOOD
FOR PEOPLE.
PEOPLE MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
CULTURAL TASTE FOR CERTAIN
FOODS.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
WE CAN ONLY PROVIDE NUTRITIOUS
FOOD FOR PEOPLE.
>> YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THESE HOTELS.
WHILE THAT GOES ON, FLORIDA IS
GRAPPLING WITH A SURGE OF
MIGRANTS ARRIVING ON THEIR
SHORES, DESANTIS SENDING IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD, CLAIMING HE GOT
NO HELP FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE'RE WORKING.
I WOULD TELL THE WHITE HOUSE,
NOT ONLY HAS THE COAST GUARD
ASKED US TO HELP, BUT WE HAVE NO
CHOICE TO HELP BECAUSE OF YOUR
NEGLECT AND INCOMPETENCE.
>> WHILE SOUNDING LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD, ATTACKING THE GOVERNOR,
THE WHITE HOUSE, WATCH THIS.
>> GOVERNOR DESANTIS HAS MADE A
MOCKERY OF THE SYSTEM, AND HE
HAS CONSISTENTLY AND CONSTANTLY,
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE REPORTED,
HAS DONE POLITICAL STUNTS, HAS
NOT HELPED TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE,
BUT HAS INSTEAD DECIDED TO PUT
THE LIVES OF MIGRANTS WHO ARE
COMING HERE FOR A BETTER LIFE AT
RISK.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
THIS GOVERNOR.
>> SO GERALDO, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
>> I WONDER WHY.
>> WHEN I'M READING THIS STORY,
RIGHT, I'M THINKING ABOUT
LAZARUS' PEOPLE ON THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY, GIVE ME YOUR TIRED,
YOUR POOR, YOUR HUDDLED MASSES,
YEARNING TO BREATHE FREE.
I'M THINKING THERE'S A TEAR
COMING DOWN THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY, WHEN SHE HEARS THE FOOD
IS NOT EXACTLY WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE, AND THERE'S MAYHEM GOING
ON IN THE HOTELS, WHERE PEOPLE
ARE ALSO, ACCORDING TO THIS
WHISTLEBLOWER, HAVING SEX IN THE
HALLWAYS, HAVING FIGHTS,
DOMESTIC ABUSE IS TAKING PLACE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> YOU'RE ASKING ME TO VOUCH FOR
THE CHAOS IN THE HOTEL?
I'M GOING TO TAKE -- I'M GOING
TO GASLIGHT SOMETHING SLIGHTLY.
I WANT TO READ YOU SOMETHING
FROM THE CARNEGIE INSTITUTE.
QUOTE, IMMIGRANTS, INCLUDING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE INCARCERATED, IN
PRISONS, CONVICTED OF CRIMES, OR
ARRESTED THAN NATIVE BORN
AMERICANS.
THAT MEANS MATHEMATICALLY
SPEAKING, THE MORE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS YOU HAVE A COMMUNITY,
THE LOWER THE CRIME RATE.
>> WE'LL HAVE A SAFER AMERICA.
>> A SAFER NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW WHO'S IN
THAT HOTEL.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A LIFE
LIKE THAT, IT'S TOTALLY
DISTORTED.
I DON'T KNOW THE STORY.
I SAW THERE'S -- I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR
IT.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU JUST SAY THAT'S
DESPICABLE?
>> IT IS DESPICABLE.
IT IS HORRIBLE.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
I'M NOT GOING TO DEFEND GARAGE,
DRINKING CORONA INSTEAD OF
MODELO.
THAT HAPPENS, THAT IS ON THE
PEOPLE, THE RESIDENTS OF THAT
HOTEL.
I AGREE.
I AM ABSOLUTE 100% SUPPORTER OF
ERIC ADAMS, WHO I'VE KNOWN SINCE
HE WAS A COP.
I DON'T KNOW THE CIRCUMSTANCES
HERE.
I REFUSE TO SAY THAT'S ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> THEY'RE THE ONLY PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE HOTEL.
>> THAT'S AN OUTRAGEOUS EXCESS
COMMITTED BY WHOEVER COMMITTED
IT, BUT TO SMEAR THE ENTIRE --
THERE ARE A MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS IN THE NEW YORK
METROPOLITAN AREA.
YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT THEM.
YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT THEM IN
CRIME STORIES.
YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT THEM
HITTING PEOPLE, THIS OR THAT.
>> OH, GERALDO.
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING, THAT'S NOT THE
REALITY, GERALDO.
PEOPLE COME HERE ILLEGALLY.
THEY DECIDE THEY'RE GOING TO
ENTER OUR COUNTRY.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, MARTHA,
IT'S HORRIBLE.
IF YOU WANT TO TRASH A HOTEL
THAT COSTS $500 A NIGHT, 2600
IMMIGRANTS IN NEW YORK CITY,
HAVING $500 HOTEL ROOMS, THAT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
IF THEY DON'T LIKE THE FOOD,
THAT'S TOO DAMN BAD.
OKAY?
LET ME GET TO THE FACTS.
WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT ILLEGALS,
BUT WE HEAR FROM THE LATIN
KINGS, THE MS-13.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT CRIME?
HOW DO WE HAVE 2 MILLION COMING
INTO THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA TOTALLY UNVETTED.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO'S A
PEDOPHILE, WHO BEATS HIS WIFE,
WHO'S A CHEAT, WHO DRIVES DRUNK,
WHO'S A THIEF, WHO'S KILLED IN
ANOTHER COUNTRY, A MEMBER OF
MS-13.
DON'T GIVE ME HOGWASH, THESE
PEOPLE DON'T COMMIT CRIMES.
WE NEED THEM FOR A SAFER
AMERICA.
THAT'S BS AND YOU KNOW IT.
>> THAT'S CARNEGIE INSTITUTE.
>> I DON'T GIVE A DAMN.
>> YOU HAVE HOMELESS VETERANS ON
THIS STREET, NOT GETTING $500
ROOMS.
TYRUS, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> AT LEAST FOUR PEOPLE ON THE
JUDGE'S LIST WERE DEFINITELY AT
THE HOTEL.
WE KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE.
THAT BEHAVIOR IS UNACCEPTABLE.
ALSO IT JUST GOES TO SHOW THAT
FREE STUFF IS NEVER GOOD STUFF.
WHETHER YOU'RE AMERICAN, FREE
STUFF, ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS
AMERICAN CITIZENS CAN'T GET FREE
STUFF.
IF YOU'RE HUNGRY -- THE
NARRATIVE BEING PUSHED EVERY
DAY, THEY'RE SEEKING ASYLUM,
OPPRESSED, RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES, FOR A FRESH START, A FREE
PLACE.
THAT IS NOT THE BEHAVIOR YOU
TYPICALLY SEE FROM THE PEOPLE
THAT GERALDO WAS DESCRIBING AND
THE PEOPLE BEING DESCRIBED.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS A
FREE-FOR-ALL, PEOPLE GOING, YAY,
FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE FLOODGATES HAVE BEEN OPENED.
THE BEST GUESS IS THAT A MILLION
GETAWAYS ARE RUNNING AROUND.
THAT'S THE BEST GUESS.
WHICH MEANS THE REALLY GOOD
ONES, THE REALLY GOOD CRIMINALS,
FIND A WAY TO SNEAK INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
IN NEW YORK WHAT ARE WE DOING?
IF YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO THROW
FOOD AWAY, MEANS YOU HAVE TOO
MUCH FOOD.
YOU HAVE TOO MANY OPTIONS.
YOU HAVE TOO MUCH FREE MONEY IN
YOUR POCKET.
MY MOTHER, SOMETIMES WE HAD
BALOGNA SANDWICHES.
IF I WANTED TO THROW IT AWAY,
THEN YOU HAD MISSED MEAL CRAMPS.
WE SAW THE PANDEMIC WITH FREE
MONEY, BAD BEHAVIOR.
NOW WE'RE SEEING IT WITH
UNDOCUMENTED, TEARING UP HOTELS
LIKE THEY HAVE ANOTHER PLACE TO
GO.
>> UH-HUH, YEAH.
JESSE?
>> HERE'S HOW STUPID ERIC ADAMS
IS, GERALDO.
HE BUILT A TENT CITY THAT COST
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON AN ISLAND
IN THE EAST RIVER.
THEY HAD CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
FOOD FOR THEM.
THEY HAD TENTS.
THEY HAD POPCORN MACHINES.
THEY HAD CRIBBAGE.
WHAT DOES HE DO, GERALDO?
HE SHUTS THE WHOLE THING DOWN.
WE PAID FOR IT.
HE SHUT IT DOWN.
NOW HE'S PAYING $500 A NIGHT
HOTEL ROOMS, WHICH THEY TRASH?
THEY'RE USING HOT PLATES TO COOK
THEIR OWN FOOD.
I UNDERSTAND AMERICAN FOOD IS
NOT THE BEST, BUT IT'S A FIRE
HAZARD.
KEEP IT AS A SNACK.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY SOMEONE GIVES
YOU A FREE SANDWICH, YOU CAME
HERE SCARED YOU'RE GOING TO GET
KILLED IN EL SALVADOR --
>> 2800 MILES.
>> HOW MUCH IS A SNACK?
DON'T THROW IT AWAY.
>> THAT WAS YOUR COLLEGE
DORMITORY.
>> THEY'